so speaking of
alpha fold the deep minds alpha fold two
recently
uh was announced to have quote unquote
solved protein folding
but how exciting is this to you it seems
to be one of the
one of the exciting things that have
happened in 2020 it's an incredible
accomplishment from the looks of it
what part of it is amazing to you what
part would you say is
over hype or maybe misunderstood
it's definitely a very exciting
achievement to give you a little bit of
perspective right so
uh so in bioinformatics we have
um several competitions and so
the way you know you often hear uh
how those competitions have been
explained to uh sort of two
non-bioinformaticians as they you know
they call it bioinformatics olympic
games
and there are several disciplines right
so so was so the the historical one of
the first one
was the discipline in predicting the
protein structure
predicting the 3d coordinates of the
proteins but there are some others so
the predicting protein functions
predicting effects
of mutations on protein functions
then uh predicting uh protein protein
interactions
so so the original one was uh casp
or a critical assessment of uh of
protein structure
um and um
the you know typically what uh
happens during these competitions is uh
you know
scientists experimental scientists uh
solve the these structures but don't put
them
into the protein data bank which is the
centralized database
that contains all these 3d coordinates
instead they hold it
and release protein sequences
and now the challenge of the community
is to predict the 3d structures
of these proteins and then use the
experimental resolve structures to
assess
which one is the closest one right and
this competition by the way just a bunch
of
different tangents and maybe you can
also say what is protein folding
uh in this competition casp competition
is
has become the gold standard and that's
what was used to say that protein
folding was solved so just to add a
little
um yeah just a bunch so if you could
whenever you say stuff uh maybe throw in
some of the basics for the folks that
might be outside of the field
anyway sorry so so yeah so you know so
the reason is
it's um you know it's relevant to
our understanding of protein folding is
because
you know we we we've yet to learn
how the folding mechanistically works
right so there are different hypotheses
what happens to this fault for example
uh
there is a hypothesis that the folding
happens by
you know in also in the modular fashion
right so that you know we have protein
domains
that get folded independently because
their structure is disabled and then
the whole protein structure gets formed
but you know
within those domains we also have
so-called secondary structure the small
alpha helices beta sheets so these are
you know uh
elements that are structurally stable
and so
and the the question is you know when
they
when do they get formed because some of
the secondary structure elements
you have to have uh you know a fragment
in the beginning and say fr the fragment
in the middle
right so so you cannot potentially start
having a the full fold from the get-go
right uh so so it's still you know it's
still a big enigma
what what happens we know that it it's
an extremely
efficient and stable process right so
there's this long sequence
and the fold happens really quickly
exactly well that's really weird right
and and it happens like the same way
almost
every time exactly exactly right really
weird
that's freaking weird it's it's yeah
that's that's why it's it's
such a amazing thing but most
importantly right so it's you know so
when when you see the
the the you know the translation process
right so
when you don't have the the the whole
uh protein translated
right it's still being translated you
know uh uh
getting out from the ribosome you you
already see some structural
you know fragmentation so so folding
starts happening before the whole
protein gets produced
right and so this is this is obviously
you know one of the
biggest questions in you know in modern
molecular biology
not not like maybe what happens like
that's not
that's bigger than the question of
folding that's the question of like
like deeper fundamental idea of folding
yes
behind folks exactly exactly so you know
so obviously
if we are able to uh
predict the end product
of protein folding we are one step
closer
to understanding sort of the mechanisms
of the protein folding
because we can then potentially look and
and start probing
what are the critical parts of this
process and what are
not so critical parts of this process so
we can start decomposing
this you know so so so in the way this
protein structure prediction algorithm
can be
can be used as a tool right so so
you change the the the you know you
modify the the protein
you get back to to this tool it predicts
okay it's completely
it's completely unstable yeah which uh
which aspects of the input will have a
big impact on the output
exactly exactly so so what happens is
you know we typically have some sort of
incremental uh advancement
you know each stage of this cusp
competition
you have groups with incremental
advancement and
you know historically uh the top
performing groups
were uh you know they were not using
machine learning they were using uh very
advanced biophysics
combined with bioinformatics combined
with you know the
the data mining uh and that was
you know that would enable them to
obtain uh protein structures
of those proteins that don't have
any structurally soft relatives
because you know if we have
another protein say the same protein but
coming from a different species
we could potentially derive some ideas
and that's so-called homology or
comparative modeling
where we'll derive some ideas from the
previously known structures
and that would help us tremendously in
uh you know in reconstructing the 3d
structure
overall but what happens when we don't
have these relatives this is when
it becomes really really hard right so
that's so-called
de novo uh uh you know uh
the nova protein structure prediction
and in this case
those methods were traditionally very
good
but what happened in the in the last
year
the original alpha fault came into
and over sudden it's much
better than everyone else this this is
2018.
yeah oh the competition is only every
two years um
i think and and then so uh
you know it was sort of kind of of a
shockwave to to to to the bioinformatics
community that you know we have
like a state-of-the-art machine learning
system
that does uh you know structure
prediction
and and essentially what it does you
know so
you know if you look at this it actually
predicts the context
so you know so so the the process of
reconstructing the
the 3d structure starts by predicting
the
the context between the different parts
of the protein and the context
essentially the parts of the proteins
that are in a close proximity to each
other
right so actually the machine learning
part seems to be
estimating you can correct me uh if i'm
wrong here but it seems to be estimating
the distance matrix which is like
the distance between the different parts
yeah so so we call the contact map
contact map right so once you have the
contact map the reconstruction
is becoming more straightforward yeah
right but so the contact map
is the key and so so uh you know so that
what happened and uh now we started
seeing in this current
stage right where in the in the most
recent one
we started seeing the emergence of these
ideas
in others uh people works right
but yet here's you know alpha fault
two yeah that's again outperforms
everyone else
and also by introducing yet another wave
of of the
of the you know machine learning ideas
yeah uh there don't seem to be also an
incorporation first of all
the paper is not out yet but there's a
bunch of ideas already out there does
seem to be an
incorporation of this other thing i
don't know if it's something that you
could
speak to which is like the incorporation
of
like other
structures like evolutionary similar
yes structures that are used to kind of
give you hints
yes so so so evolutionary similarity
uh is something that we can detect at
different levels right so
uh we know for example that this
structure
of proteins is more conserved than the
sequence
the sequence could be very different but
the structural shape
is actually still very conserved so
that's that's sort of the intrinsic
property that you know in a way related
to protein folds
you know to the evolution of the you
know of the protein
of proteins and protein domains etc but
we know that i mean we've
they've been multiple studies and uh
you know ideally if you have structures
you know you should use that information
however sometimes we don't have this
information instead we have a bunch of
sequences sequences we have a lot
right so so we we have you know
hundreds thousands of uh you know
different organisms sequenced right and
by
taking this same protein but
in different organisms and aligning it
so
making it you know making the
corresponding positions
aligned we can actually uh
[Music]
say a lot about sort of what is
conserved in this protein
and therefore you know structurally more
stable what is diverse in these proteins
so on top of that we we could provide
sort of the information about the
sort of the secondary structure of this
protein etcetera so this information is
extremely useful
and it's already there so so while it's
tempting to
you know to do a complete abhinitio so
you just have a protein sequence and
nothing else
the reality is such that we we are
overwhelmed with this data
so why not use it and
so yeah so i i'm looking forward to to
reading the the this paper
it does seem to like they've in the
previous version of alpha fold they
didn't
uh for this the evolutionary similarity
thing they didn't use
machine learning for that or they
rather they used it as like the input to
the entirety of the
the neural net like the features uh
derived from the similarity
it seems like there's some kind of
quote-unquote iterative thing
where it seems to be part of the
part of the learning process is the
incorporation of this
evolutionary similarity yeah i i don't
think there is a bioarchive paper right
there's no no
there's nothing yeah it's a blog post
that's written by a marketing team
essentially
yeah which you know it has some
scientific
uh uh similarity probably to
the the actual methodology used but it
could be
it's like interpreting scripture it
could be it could be just poetic
uh interpretations of the actual work as
opposed to direct connection to the work
so now speaking about protein folding
right so so so you know in order to
answer the question whether or not we
we have solved this right yeah so we
need to go back to
to the beginning of our conversation you
know with the realization that you know
an average protein
is that typically what uh the
the cusp uh has been focusing on is
uh the you know the this competition has
been focusing on the
single maybe two domain proteins that
are still
very compact and even those ones are
extremely challenging to
to solve right but now we talk about
you know an average protein that has two
three protein domains if you look at the
um
proteins that uh that are in charge of
the
you know of the process in you know with
the neural system right
perhaps one of the uh of the
most recently evolved sort of uh
systems in in in in a in an
organism right all of them well the
majority of them
are highly multi-domain proteins so they
are
you know some of them have five six
seven
you know and more domains right
and you know we are very far away from
understanding how these proteins are
folded
so the complexity of the protein matters
here the complex the complexity of the
protein modules or the the protein
domains
so you're saying uh solve so the
definition of solved here is
particularly the cast
competition achieving human level not
human level
achieving uh mental experimental level
performance
on these particular sets of proteins
that have been used in these
competitions
well i mean you know i i i do think that
uh
you know especially with with regards to
the alpha fault
you know it is able to uh you know
to solve you know at the
near experimental level a
pretty big majority of the of the
uh more compact proteins like or protein
domains because
again in order to understand how the
overall protein uh
you know multi-domain protein fault we
do need to understand
the structure of its individual domains
i mean unlike
if you look at alpha zero or like even
mu zero
if you look at that work you know there
it's nice reinforcement learning
self-playing mechanisms are nice because
it's all in simulation so you can
learn from just huge amounts like you
don't need data
like the problem with proteins like the
size
uh i forget how how many 3d structures
have been mapped but the training data
is very small
no matter what it's like millions maybe
a one or two million or something like
that
but some very small number but like it
doesn't seem like that's scalable
there has to be i don't know it feels
like you want
to somehow 10x the data or 100x the data
somehow
yes but we also can take advantage of
uh of uh homology
models right so the models that are of
very
good quality because they are
essentially
obtained based on the evolutionary
information
right so so you can there is a potential
to enhance this
information and uh you know use it
again uh to to empower the
the uh the training set um
and it's i think i i am actually
very optimistic i think it's been
one of this uh sort of uh
you know uh churning events
where you have a system
that is you know a machine learning
system
that is truly better than the sort of
the
more conventional by physics based
methods
that's a huge leap
you